well i mean so much has happened today
so let's kind of rewind a bit and take a
detailed look at what precipitated
tonight's dramatic events and remind you
of the timeline of those shifting
explanations from downing street which
so enraged it seems some ministers over
the claims against chris pincher so
these accusations of sexual misconduct
against the former deputy chief whip
have been reported on several occasions
over many years it's turned out the
focus of today's intervention by the
former senior civil servant lord
macdonald was a formal complaint made in
the foreign office where he was working
at the time in 2019 when mr pincher was
a foreign office minister he apologized
for his actions and lord macdonald says
the prime minister was briefed about
that complaint against chris pincher in
person well despite this
last friday downing street first said
boris johnson had no knowledge of the
allegations when his longtime supporter
was appointed again to the whips office
officials then changed their account
yesterday then they said that the prime
minister didn't know of any specific
unresolved allegations
and then today came a third account when
a downing street spokesperson said the
prime minister was told about complaints
against mr pincher in 2019
but forgot